Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Diep.io
Now in this game, we're going to be playing domination
-of which I have never played. I've never even started a game; I've never explored it; this is completely new territory for me,
and it may be new territory for some of you guys.
So, okay. So there's two teams.
There's some weiiiiiird yellow boxes over there; I don't know what they do..... but they do something.....
Soooo, what is the thing that they do?,  'cause I don't know....
Why are these guys just standing here
Oh my god, are they the--- the desecrated relics of the--- of the--- of my former teammates? I've no idea.
So what are these yellow squares?
OOOOOOOOOH! *gasp
What is thaaaaat?
Ohhhhhh, what is that?
Ohhhh, WHAT is THAT?
Oh, that's cooooool
Ah, shit
God damn it
I'm getting too eager in the beginning of the game
Oh shit
But that's coool
What is that?
I want to KNOOOOOOOOW
WOOOOO
WOOOOOOOO
Okay.
Ah jeez
Alright, I'm gonna go a different route than I usually go.....
Let's see, I went sniper before......
I don't know if I waaaaant to do thaaaaaaaat
I've never done flank guard
I've never really done flank guard before, so I'm going to try this a little bit
It's nice to have some reverse engineering going on here so that I don't have to worry about people sneaking up behind me
I got a--- I'm a I'm a--- I'm---
*Confused Mark*
I'm---
mmm
Bi--- bifurcated
Nevermind, you know what, I'm not gonna, I'm not gonna do that
It's a bad idea
Oh jeez
OH OH
He's gonna shoot!
AHHH
He SHOT!
Well, this isn't good
Okay, thi--a-- this- this got- | this changes up my thinking because now I have to worry about fricking which direction I'm going in; like, holy crap
WHOA WHOA WHOA buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy bu--cu--- Come, come on, come on, come on
So what happens if we kill these guys?
Like, obviously it looks like we can only really-- WHOAAAA THAAAAAT IS DANGEROUS
Holy shit, I was not ready for that, okay.
Soooooo
Let's---
fricking do something again
Alright
Flank guard, bullet pen
Good god, I was not ready for that
So I imagine that we've got to try to kill these things, and preferably get the last hit on them, I imagine, is what the win condition is actually gonna be
Shit
Ahh shit
Anybody gonna help me out with this?
Is this what we actually want to do or is this---
Why I'm glad it's on me and nobody else
I-- I'm helping the team, right? There's credit for this gonna happen, right?
Oh shit, WHOAAAAAA, hey
The SE [South East] dominator is now controlled by the red?
*high pitched* What does that mean?
I don't know what that means; what's the SE dominator?
UHHHHHHHHHHH
ALL THESE NEW THINGS, I DON'T KNOW MAN
Whoa, someone is coming in hot and heavy
HOT 'N' HEAVY
AHHHHH
I gotta go level up
Ohhhhhhhhh, that guy got ownnnnne-duh
Okay, so I imagine that when you kill that thing you're going to get a thing... to compliment your...... thiiiiiiing
Body damage? Fuck, I didn't want body damage, god damn it! I did--- fuuuuuck.
Ohhhhhh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit
Shit
God damn it
I almost died just from that
I wasn't ready for it!
I wasn't ready!
Man, I would-- I would hate to think that some people have pro strats in this bullshit
Someone already knows how to dominate a team from just playing this stupid mode
WAAAAAAAAA--- It's not stupid, but I--- j-just right now  I have no idea what I'm doing, so, because I'm stupid: this seems stupid.
The north--- Ohhhh, the north west dominator, why did they go for that dominator? Oh god
Oh, so those things are dominators--- that was south east dominator is what it was saying, so I was just too----
*Redneck accent* Too stupid to understand what that meant, I don't know my cardinal directions very well *End Accent*
Ohhh shit, someone is--
Someone is playing very aggressively over here
And I appreciate it, but I'd appreciate it more if it was on my god damn team
Not their god damn team; there we go, north east dominator is now controlled by the blue
So I imagine you win when you control all of these quote unquote dominators
So when the hell is that gonna happen
Whoa
Ueeeegh (?)
Don't kill me bro
Okay, actually I'm gonna do twin flank, I think th---- yeaaaaaah, this is what I wanted. Hell yeah, man! Oh, this is waaaay better.
Oh, this is waaay better.
Oh yeah, get 'em, get 'em, get 'em buddy, get 'em; oh wow, that was---
Wow, they take some--- they take some patterns. Oh, I push 'em out of the way with my boolets!
Ooooooh
Nice
Nice nice nice-- AH; oohkay, don't push 'em towards me, god damn it
AHH, AHHHH, oh don't push 'em towards me, that's instant death! That's inSTANT death!
Get 'em, get 'em, get 'em guys
You're welcome; you're welcome for this; I'm helping
IIIIIIIII'M HELPING!
Oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez, oh jeez, ORGIES, ORGIES; WHOoooOOOOA fuck, it's so dangerous, this is so scary AHHHHA-- it's so scary
I just need to stop shooting at 'em when they're coming my way
Unless they actually are smart
There we go; oh shit
Our teammates just got bbbbblasted away
Okay, here we go; yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, get 'em, yeah, get 'em; nooooo, don't get too close
Oh god!
This doesn't seem good for us, this seems bad, but our whole team is behind this
Ohhh, this is unity
This is unity unlike any other
Ohhhh, sorry for getting in your way beaver
WOOOOOOOOOOOOO
It's on our side now, baby!
Oh, come get some!
We got the whole might of the blue armada on the--- welllllll; I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared, I killed someone but I'm scared
Yeee--- *unintelligible noises*
Okay, someone's over here and they're getting a lot of bull----- whooooo, heeey
Okay, so we gotta--- mmmmmmmuuuu--- THEY'RE COMING FOR THIS ONE, I don't want to let 'em have it
I mean, I'm gonna let 'em have it, but they're not gonna haaaaaaave it
Is what I mean by that
Ohhh, it's twin on twiiiiiin
Twin on twiiieeeiiiin
Oh shit
I'm not high enough level for this
*high pitched scream* AHHHHHHHHHHHH
AHHHH
OH GOD, SO MANY BULLETS; uhh, uhh, uhh, pullin' out, pullin' out,  I'm bailin'
I think I might go, i-- in this mode, I think I might actually go for the cannonball, because the cannonball--- I KILLED HELP, YAAAAAAAAAAAAAY
Because the cannonball is extremely high damage, and if I can just get close
Then I can...... bash 'em up a bit
I wonder what our team is doing, are they off on the sides trying to level up
Where's my chat?!?
Where can---- oh god, oh that's good, no that's good, they all went to the--- oooOOOOOOOOOOHHH
whOOOOOOOOOAAA
Triple twin or octa tank?
Huuuuuuuuhhh
I like the idea of OCTA TAAAAAAAAAAANK
AUGHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
AUGHHHHHHHHHHHHH; I SPIN SO FAST I SHOOT IN JUST A FEW DIRECTIONS
OCTA TAAAAAANK
If you control your rotation, you really do-
Shoot in just a few directions, but it's good
It's a good thing
It's bad for doing single target damage, like on this guy
BuuuuuUUUUUUt
It's good for other things too.....
North east, ah man, they took the north east back, damn it!
Yeah, the octa tank
The octa tank might have definitely been a mistake
I'm not a hundred percent sure about this
WHOOOOOOOOO, that's a lot of bullets in a very specific direction where I got a lot of bullets in a very...... GEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEENERAL direction
UHHHHHHH
UHHHHHH
*starts singing* I'm helping! I'm helping!
Kind of, maybe, not really, holy shit this is kinda bad
Ah fuuuuuuck, ah fUUUUUUUuck
Ah fucky, fucky, fuuuuuuuck
Ah shitbags, oh dickhole, oh god I'm gonna die now; holy crap
I shoved that little guy in the way, yeah
I'm such a----
piece of shit!
But I'm gonna survive; *ends singing* oh god no I'm not
AHHHHhhhhhhhhhhhh
Whoa, what is that big guy; what is killa?
I wanna know what killa is, he seems like some sorta super sniper
I like that
I like thaaaaat
Yeeeeeeeeeeeeeesssss, YEEEEEEEEEEEEEESSSSSSSSSS
I--- I was part of that; he died but I was part of it
It's because I helped
Oh, that's not good
HEEEEEEY, I KILLED HIM, YEAAAH, I KILLED HIM, YEAAAAAAAAH, I got a lot of points for that!
Fifty eight thousand, I'm probably on the leaderboard but there isn't a leaderboard in this gamemode
But that-- that removes one of their---
One of their, uhhh, higher level players
From.... the roster, which is good for us.....
Is that getting faster?
I don't like the s---- I don't like the sound of that
Yeah, there we go!
It's contested!
And now------
Should be able to, spin to win it
WHOAAAAAA, that's not good, I'm dead, I'm dead, I'm de----- AHHHHHHHHH
FUUUUUUUUUUUUCK MEEEE, NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
I didn't like that at all, I'm gonna try the twin again
Yeaaaaah, we got the north east one, even though I got fucked up
Totally by accident and wasn't my fault at all
It caught me off guard on a bad day, wasn't my fault
Alright, triple shot, quad tank, twin flank, OHHH I guess I can go on different upgrade paths
Well, I don't really like the triple shot, but I'll take it
Okay, I'm gonna go for the south east one soon, I just--- I just need to level up, I- I- I need to be, like higher level or else this isn't gonna work out for me
That guy's almost dead
ACHOO OOOH (bless you)
Okay, almost max level, almost there, almost there, almost there baby
Are we getting YEAAAAAAAAAAAAH, we're gettin' this thing
We're gettin' it!
Changin' it over, okay we got this, we got this, we got this
WHOAAAAAAAAAAAAA, we're gonna win this, we're gonna win this baby
We're gonna win it!
I wish it would give you like, minute score for hitting it, but I guess that's part of the strategy; you either got to hit or you gotta go farm up
YEAAAAAAAH, WE GOT IT
OHH, THREE OF FOUR
Whoaa, heeey, whoa, that's a lot of bullets
Holy sheit
But this is awesome, I love this mode
This is a good mode
Alright, so we just gotta go for the last one, it looks like everyone's making a final push anyway
I wish I was just a little higher level, just a few more points
Ahhh, just a few more points
There's not gonna be any nearby just because it's sooooo stocked up
There's so many people in this area
OOOOOOOH I think we're gonna get it
*sings again* Think we're gonna get it
Gonna get it
Think we're gonna get it
We're gonna get it
Whoa shit, that's----
A lotta red
Oh shit that's-----
Not gonna matter, because we're gonna get it yeah! *end singing* Look out, Alan, ALAN; oh jeez Alan
Wow, Alan
Alan
Holy crap
We got it, we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it, we got it, we DOOOODOOOO DODODDODODODODO
YEAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH BABY YEAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH
WOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
BLUE HAS WON THE GAME
YEAAAAAAAAAAH
BLUUUUUUUUUUUUE
Heh
Okay, anyway
So, that is the end of the game; arena is closed: no players can join, so it's just a murder spree until everyone decides to leave, but----
That is what this game is. Who is shooting yellow bullets?
What the hell was that?
Oh my god, I've------ oh my god
OH GOD
IT'S THE ARE---- OH GOD
It's the arena closer, holy shit
Oh god
They're so scary
But, either way; that is domination gamemode, I highly suggest you give it a try because it's very fun
And gives a new depth to the game, so---
Thank you everybody, so much for watching---
and as always..... I will see YOU, in the next video (We love you Mark!)
Bye-bye!
Mark: I STABBED YOOOOOOOOU
Bob: No, no no, I think I hit you first.
Mark: SON OF A BITCH
Mark: No, NOOO---- NOOOOOOOOO